let me ask you a question of of the guys
I'm sure you see millionaires right
would you say that
those guys have good strong connections
with their wives no because obviously
they come to me because of what so like
I said like the wife after the third the
first kid has been like let herself go
down they come to me because because I
have the lingerie set because I'm
wearing makeup I'm wearing my fake
lashes I have my nails done and
obviously like in my case I don't even
look like a trans woman most of the time
and
even because like for example as and
I've been told by so many men
are you're different from the other
trans women
and then I even went to my psychologist
one and a while and I asked him
why I have these men coming to me and
telling me like Regina you're different
than the other trans women
and like my psychologist told me oh it's
because like you've been you were born a
woman
okay um in fact like I came out to my
family when I was
four and my family has accepted that
since I was four
and I started transitioning like with my
head
than like a body and hormones and
everything
before I was a teenager like I've been
treated as Regina I'm from a family
since I was four
like the guy came out so you came out to
your family at four and they identified
you as a woman yeah because like for
example I used to have nightmares when I
was when I was like your mom and your
dad both did my mom my dad my
grandmother and my grandfather because
in South America is not just that the
small nuclear of the family like Mom and
Dad it's everyone who accepted this
um in kudos to them that's exactly what
they should have done
do you think the launch what I hear is I
do my lingerie I do the nails I do the
makeup
it probably in some way makes that man
feel like you went through some trouble
to try to please him in some way which
means that you were trying to like be
subservient in that way do you think
that's the thing that draws them in
because they tell you that what do you
think it is about you doing those things
that men like
uh
honestly I don't I don't really know but
like I mean I know that I'm doing it at
this um
so at the very beginning I was doing it
for myself
like because I wanted to be accepted
more like a woman break from the society
and then like I actually understood that
it's then liking it
so it's like
giving you know like because when you
give the treat to the but do you think
it's it's partly just down to this thing
that we've been talking about which is
that they want variety right I mean
they've been with these wives for
however long maybe it's you know it's
it's it's it's gone down that you know
it's gone down a little bit in terms of
the passion in the marriage and then
they're looking for some sort of variety
and that's what they come to you I'm I'm
curious do this man like specifically
seek out trans prostitutes do these men
specifically seek out trans prostitutes
so basically like what can I say is
there's loads of confusion right now in
everyone's head because like I've got
guys coming to me that they're like oh I
don't know if I'm this
or I don't know if I'm there
they don't know if they're a man or a
woman like if they're gay or straight
and I'm like you know what
a gay men will never go with a trans
woman because a gay man will seek
another gay men
and uh
is like a
lesbian woman will never go with the
amen but do they specifically like seek
out like so they do like for example in
my case they message me and they're like
oh how big are you and I'm like um you
know I don't know because um it's not
something that I do
and they're like also why are you doing
this job for and I'm like so why you
asking me questions for that they're not
already answered on my ad but when
you're advertising you're advertising as
as a trans woman yeah yeah
and they ask you how big you are in
regards to the member so you don't think
those men are homosexual yeah I do yeah
because and they're like trying to deny
the fact of their homosexuality
covering it by going with a trans woman
right because they're gonna be like okay
she's a woman like
on image right but then I know what
we're doing in the bedroom but like as
well at the end of the day if a trans
woman is a real trans woman
she's having a psychological problem
with her sex
like a
why if you are a smart person
why would you even go
and touch that psychological problem
more than
how it's not already because like as I
said if I'm not showing something on my
advertisement
why would you come and ask me about that
yeah okay because if it's not advertised
like like being an escort is being like
putting yourself in a shop
in the like in divitrine of the shop
and I'm showing you already by pictures
and videos what I'm gonna offer I
obviously probably wrote as well a
presentation
that most of the people doesn't even
read so you can even write like a hello
my name is uh these and I want to do
this but I'm gonna do that because I
want to do it they will never read it so
I and you don't have to answer this if
that's offensive at all but you said you
transitioned you started like
transitioning from four
yeah like that that sounds a bit sad to
me because it's like how did you how did
you know what you
wanted at four you know because I and I
just say this because I was a bit of a
tomboy because like they let me choose
what how I wanted to work with so
because for example
it was Monday morning and I had to go to
school obviously when it's back in
Venezuela I had to wear the uniform so
it was neutral
because in my school like the girls
wouldn't even wear skirts because it was
an Evangelistic okay school and like
everyone was wearing jeans yeah
because they wanted like everyone to be
the same yeah but then like in on the
daily things they will let me choose
what I wanted to do and like any
whenever I was inclined for they will
accept it because they were like a
whoever she wants to be
I want we want a happy
to be who she wants to be and why we
will have to
like a preclude someone to not be to
someone to not be someone that they
don't want to be so when did you start
like growing your hair out wearing
makeup how old were you I said so
basically because my families are really
so my family is their politicians and my
from my grandmother's side which comes
from the Irish family from Spain
I had to wait like all my cousins until
I became 13 to wear makeup presumably
Venezuela is quite traditional as well
though right I mean is it fairly
conservative sort of country
um yeah it's very Christian it's a kind
of similar to Brazil
and but it can it can be even worse
right because Brazil as it's like a
Portuguese community and it's a
Portuguese colony
it's more on their own
yeah Brazil's like the only place in
South America that we don't we're not
Hispanic we're Latina but we're not
Hispanic we haven't seen views but it's
more like Western but still then it's
still very sorry bestowed and it's like
very conservative yeah yeah the whole of
South America but Brazil was mostly
Western right yeah yeah I mean I do
imagine your parents or your family must
be somewhat liberal
[Music]
he's always been on the opposition
like opposition to the communism
oh he's not a communist no he's right
wing okay no no no because like for
example Venezuela it's a it's a
communist country now like nothing comes
out of Venezuela no infos
nothing goes in it's becoming like even
more and more every year like um North
Korea um
like even me like sometimes I can't even
talk to my family because they don't
have internet oh wow and then like
sometimes and I as I said my grandmother
She's suffering of dementia and my mom
too
they both gone together at the same time
and I am the one like now trying to help
some time somehow like trying to speak
with with a nurse and I'm like sometimes
I'm even having like three weeks where I
know I don't know anything about them
and I'm like um
I always
say like
I always wait for a signal like from I
don't know from God or whatever because
anyway they always say like if you're
really close to your family you're gonna
feel when someone is gone
and I remember even when I felt my
grandfather when my grandfather died
like no one told me but I felt like
someone killed me
and that's how what I can think of her
like a
of a man of a woman as well of um you
know as far as of a high level of high
standards is when they teach you like a
that love goes no matter what
you just don't need money you just don't
need anything else
I'm really surprised your family was so
um accepting it sounds like they're
conservative
sir like
I think it's a
yeah they wear but with me they always
had like that
um I don't know it's probably because I
was born premature and stuff so they
were like okay let's
keep her on a bubble but like not too
much and
and as well like they had examples of
other families where like I don't know
the kid was like turning against their
family
and plus as well by being a family
always constantly under the the lights
and stuff like that they didn't want
like Givens well like you know like
having a granddaughter or grandson uh 16
years old that hangs himself and end up
on the newspaper
[Music]
like if it's something that I would have
they wanted to accept you yeah and as
well like I I think it's something that
I will have to sit down with my
grandmother which is like a night on her
90s but in her head she's 25. and she's
telling me how she's living her best
life at 25 years old and I'm like all
right yeah do you feel like it's a fair
statement that
parents should have their child wait
until they hit puberty and adulthood
before having a surgery
let them play that out yeah like of
having a final surgery yeah I will I
will always suggest everyone no matter
what like wait until you can choose
yourself as an adult and you've been
through puberty and you've been through
the feelings that you have sexually when
you go through preview because I just
although your story is very beautiful I
would not want it to misrepresent that
it is child abuse to cut a child before
they even hit puberty or have the
ability to be an adult and make an adult
decision for example in my case I
haven't took any like an appeal any
block here any okay any
until I was like until I was
13.
which is when I chose
whether I took it oh that's so young
that's so young which is where I choose
whether I wanted to take it or not and I
was like yeah I want it
but do you know do you know why um I
kind of like that I think not especially
now that you you know that you don't
want to go back but it's like me even
when I'm 21 now but even when I was at
17 I was such a tomboy like I've changed
so much like even now I feel like I'm
still trouble I feel like I'm getting
more and more feminine yeah but I think
it's because culture wise as well at the
same time like she said as well before
like um in South America you are like
undirected onto things
but it seems to me that surely it'll
almost be the other way around because
in South America it seems like it's more
conservative particularly because you're
saying you know you come from quite a
conservative family so it seems
surprising that you know you're
relatively Young when you started to do
this I would have thought it would be
more like the other way around they
would have made you wait for a bit
longer yeah no but like I always think
like it comes as well like a
with the background of the family and
everything yeah like like I said like
they're quite International more or less
and as well like my grandmother's family
has a background on their aristocracy in
Spain that they were like all right we
shouldn't be judging older ones
it is surprising because it would have
been in the 90s if you'd have been four
you're 28 yeah yeah so it had been 95 96
you were born I was born in 95. yeah so
it's just a completely different world
that they weren't aware in the same way
so it is a bit surprising
them I just believe and the reason I'm
bringing it up and I think the reason I
got where we got earlier is because I
kind of knew and
I'm sitting here and I knew
in
me and you were talking but they are
listening and your situation is so much
different if I'm being fair from theirs
and
I just think it's important
that number one that I acknowledge that
I think it's beautiful that your family
loved you but at the same time your
situation is going to be substantially
different than the young lady sitting on
the couch yeah that's why I said to her
as well like my situation is different
it's different as well yeah and that's
why I even like on my own side I can
tell that there were so many things
where I would agree with you so many
things where I will agree with you so
many things where I will agree with them
and not like
I was trying to be ultimate matching
partial I could but like when I feel
like someone is trying to impose in
themselves and I'm gonna say like I'm
trying because I could have like a
misjudged and like uh took it in another
way that should I have fun it's
completely fine I do have a genuine
question for you I didn't mean to cut
you off but
when you said you quite enjoy the work
I don't think a man
any man if they were told hey you can
you can get paid to have sex all day
would would not do that deal that's a
pretty cool gig do you feel like you
have the sex drive
of a woman or do you think do you
have you ever felt you know that urge
I'm talking about you know I know what
you what you're talking about
I am pretty sure that my sexual life
eats
normal the drive yeah no even the drive
like in my way woman or a man in my in
my case it's a more psychological it's
not physical anymore at my point as well
in age and time where I've been taking
as well like the appeals and stuff
I see things in a different way with two
different sides yes
I can feel things in two different ways
yeah because at the end of the day even
though like
I am a woman and I feel like a woman and
I'm gonna be a woman and I am a woman no
matter what
I still have the possibility like to
have like a
a masculine and a feminine thought which
everyone actually could have that way
because
at the end of the day when we are in our
mother's belly we have no sex until a
certain point but anyone everyone comes
from a neutral thing
but can I have a question and this is in
no like because that you said your story
and I find it so beautiful and that you
even have the strength to even say it
here but do you think it's like
respectful to say that you are a woman
instead of like trans women like do you
like make a point to say trans women or
is it okay for you to just say I don't
like it like I always try to specify I
am a trans woman yeah okay because I'm
transitioning I'm learning as well at
the same time like everyone it is
because everyone is transitioning in
life
so I want to fully transitioned like we
feel comfortable to just say to someone
I'm a woman and without the trans yeah
in that way yes
okay
but because like there's I know but at
the end of the day well you know you
wouldn't be an actual woman
what makes a woman like a menstruation
the YouTubers because there's so much
things that make you yeah you know
there's women there's women that they
but they were born without uterus
because they had a malformation we're
looking at exceptions not the rule so I
would say generally it's women that can
have kids women that have ovaries women
that have or don't have a penis yeah
like any of those things so it's just
like what it would never bother me like
the only thing that would get to me is
that if if a woman that would try to
give a young woman advice
you know you know what I'm saying
because I know that what's inside of me
even if I started calling myself a woman
is completely different than what might
be in a young lady well like then like
my question is why have I been invited
men and women are invited to the podcast
yeah and then like I don't know I feel
like I'm being told like you're not any
of them and we're here to give other
suggestions to young women no you are no
I'm not saying that you're not no I'm
not I'm not talking oh okay
but I mean like you're not a woman
you're a trans woman I was responding
because you said that you were gonna say
you're a woman in the future and I said
no you wouldn't be
well like um that's uh and you you know
like uh I always say like you should
think about before you say those kind of
things because you never know like I
don't know how how would you feel if
then tomorrow someone is calling you
like my manager he's calling you and
tells you you know Regina has hanged
herself because she didn't like the
words you used then I would say Regina
was weak probably she probably was weak
yeah but you know why she was we ran
away from her problems people call me
really mean things on the internet me
too yeah I know like and I know it for
sure in person I've been attacked on
this oh yeah even me every day yeah so I
I please don't do that but I don't think
you should kill yourself because someone
called you yeah but that's why I'm still
alive what that's why I'm still alive
because I haven't hugged myself because
someone hasn't called me you're not a
woman right but I just think I'm just
not a liar
like I just I'm not gonna lie so when
it's like when you say something that's
not true I'm not going to tell you it's
true yeah but that's because that's your
opinion as well
scientific fact I don't even think it's
just that as well like I think because
your story is so commendable and
everything and you're going through the
transition you should feel proud to say
I'm a trans woman I was watching this
video of this trans lady the other days
it was from like the 80s and she said um
Zach I'm proud to say I'm trying to I
just don't know if I can say that and
I'm just trying to be honest I just
don't know if I can say that giving
drugs to someone at 13 is commendable
yeah you know I'm glad it like worked
out for you you seem happy but I just
think like if I would say that's a
command but that's your repeat
yeah that's my story because like now
because if you are if you do you know
other trans women or other trans people
because now you have to you have to wait
until you're 18 or even 21 25 26. in my
case it's because I come from another
country maybe rules might it might be
different and
I'm glad it worked out but to me it's
still sad like honestly I was getting
sad yeah but like that because that's 13
that's okay yeah but like for me and to
me then to me can be sad like yours the
story of your life because you've been
precluded onto something else
like everyone can everyone has their
story and their rights to write their
story and to tell their story so like
and you can tell it like I'm not telling
you don't tell it I'm just we're talking
about it yeah no and as well like I'm
like I said you have your opinion it's
good for you to have an opinion I have
another one
yeah I just I just can't imagine like 13
is just so like that's so young to me
because I think of myself when I was 13
I dressed like a freaking man and like I
said because it's because it's a
different culture it's a different
culture I think it's more than just
dressing like obviously I don't know
personally but I think obviously it's
chemicals and what's the thoughts and of
going on in your brain so I don't think
you can relate it to like your own
personal situation because that that
stuff's not okay I could because you
know honestly
if I did have a thought like that and
Society encouraged it or my parents
encourage it who knows maybe I'd be down
the same path I don't know but it's like
are you dressing like a tomboy did you
have thoughts of okay maybe this is
something actually that I need to dig
deeper in and actually think about well
because my parents would never let me no
but it's not about you yeah
and they were your parents choosing for
you in that case my parents they would
never choose for me yeah my parents
chose because because my parents they
say you have a right to speak and you
have your right to think I think I think
the difference is though I I think it's
good that my parents chose for me in a
lot of situations because when you're
young you can make choices that affect
the rest of your life I'll give you an
example
um not so much as gender transitioning
but tattoos like I'm really glad I don't
have any tattoos but when I was younger
I wanted I wanted to get them to piss my
mom off I'm not saying that's a good
thing to do but but they said no you
can't ever do that so like I don't know
just drugs you know like I should I have
to say though like you know I I think I
I'm on this debate I'm more side with a
lot of women who feel like the the
experience of Womanhood is two two
personal spiritual Divine and they you
know sometimes they reject the idea of
you know a trans woman Etc and um I
don't I think I form on that side but I
I have a massive amount of respect for
you for your personal experience I can't
imagine what it's like to feel like you
you're supposed to be in another body
that must be crazy just hearing you is
like you know me trying to empathize is
like kind of wild because I'm thinking
that that is wild imagine if you felt
like that and if I'm honest I will never
put myself on the same like level of a
woman who was born woman and I will
never try to do that because there are
two different stories two different
lives two different kind of environments
I will never go through what a woman
goes through as as the same way a woman
will never go through
to what I'm going through definitely
okay I'm glad I'm glad that that's
acknowledged right I have a lot of
respect for for people like you and like
your personal experience 100
um and personal identity
um but yeah agreed as many of you know I
was just banned on Tick Tock and we are
demonetized on a daily basis on this
platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible